woman with pitchfork and whip arrested
outside Publix in Florida
if you have a whip in your car and you
don't use it you're like what did I even
get this for so much of my childhood and
you had the whip everybody had whips
every kid in Wisconsin bought whips so
Dan just wanted to be Indiana Jones
and outside on the front yard lawn just
be like oh oh yeah let's go down at the
lake and you're just whipping people and
it wraps around their ankle and you pull
them off the back someone hot no one
died how did you not all go to the
hospital I know no one put an eye out
with the whip we all whipped each other
is it is it easy to grab someone's ankle
with a whip when it's wet
you do it and it just it rips around
yeah one of my brothers once yeah they
were standing on a rock and uh and I
just went and parents who are out
watching were like what do you even do
their kids had whips
[Music]
don't take that from him